whether they feature brutal murders or
Zombie Invasions these horror movie
openings are bound to hook you in and
haunt your dreams in 1977 a razor head
marked the debut of the one and only
Master Of The Surreal David Lynch with a
resume as unconventional as his it holds
a lot of weight to say that's his first
feature-length offering Remains the most
experimental of his entire filmography
this exercise in bleakness follows Henry
Spencer as he unexpectedly becomes a
father of a seemingly inhuman baby the
opening scene of a race ahead
immediately sets the film's oppressive
tone and smothering atmosphere much of
the film takes place in a surreal
industrial landscape but the very first
moment is set away from any identifiable
setting we see a double exposure of
Henry's frightened face as he Glides
from side to side in front of something
resembling an alien planet elsewhere
disfigured man credited as the man in
the planet Paul's levers as a bizarre
organism slithers its way out of Henry's
mouth at face value this opening scene
might not seem like it has anything to
do with the rest of the film however
some fans believe that the opening scene
is a key to understanding the entire
movie a lever pulling represents sexual
intercourse and the organism exiting
Henry and entering the planet represents
conception of course the nature of
Lynch's abstract storytelling and his
refusal to discuss his intentions means
that his movies are always open to
numerous interpretations Believe It or
Not Eraserhead is my most spiritual film
elaborate on that no
starring a much more Sinister than usual
Elijah Wood 2012's Maniac is a remake of
the 1980 horror film of the same name
both films tell the story of a deranged
serial killer with a mannequin Obsession
and mommy issues who stalks the streets
of New York City looking for women to
scalp mod sets to remake apart as French
director Frank colfoon's decision to
present the entire film from a first
person perspective the creative use of
point of view in Maniac makes a violence
much more disturbing than it would be
otherwise and the film's opening scene
capitalizes on its unique presentation
style Through The Eyes of the killer the
audience watches as he finds stalks and
closes in on his victim in painstaking
detail the level of realism is high and
woods heavy breathing as he sneaks it
behind his unsuspecting Target makes a
scene unbearably uncomfortable even
before the actual violence starts when
the time does finally come the first
person POV showcases the kill in full
graphic detail not cutting away until
it's finally over rather than checking
back in with Jim Selena and Hannah from
the British zombie Masterpiece 28 Days
Later it's sequel 28 Weeks Later wipes a
storytelling slate clean and follows a
new set of characters and a rage
infected England a narrative reset like
that for a sequel puts a lot of weight
on the opening scene luckily 28 Weeks
Later Rose to the challenge with its
intro even if the rest of the film comes
up short when compared to the original
in other areas in what is probably the
peak of the film the opening sequence
introduces a new group of survivors
living out the zombie apocalypse in an
isolated Cottage audiences begin to get
to know them individually but the
infected bust in and tear them apart
before the end of the intro with
character development World building
action and Gore the opening sequence of
28 Weeks Later feels like a strong
Zombie short film all on its own the
hard-hitting soundtrack also adds a lot
to the scene especially as Lone Survivor
done Sprints across a field with zombies
hot on his tail the sequence works great
in isolation but it also sets the rest
of the film's plot in motion Don's
decision to choose self-preservation and
about than his wife instead of trying to
save her leaves her reunion with his
children in the now militarized London
his shocking split-second decision even
comes back to bite him when it turns out
that his wife didn't die after all you
said you saw her die
you did
yoshikurasawa's 1997 J horror hits cure
Stars Koji yakusho as a detective
investigating a string of bizarre and
seemingly random murders even though
they all seem to be carried out by
different Killers the victims all have
gory X's carved into their bodies before
our detective protagonist has even
introduced though cure gets started by
showing one of the murders as it unfolds
the opening scene follows an
unidentified man as he rips a pipe off a
wall in the transit tunnel meets up with
a woman in a hotel room then beats her
to death wordlessly and without motive
the way the scene is sharp makes a
violence hard to watch there's no fancy
camera movements or flourishes just a
man taking an innocent woman's life what
makes the scene even more disturbing
however is that after the man kills her
he snaps out of a trance with no memory
of what he just did it's all set to some
surprisingly cheerful music that makes
the whole thing much more creepy be sure
to check out cure if you enjoy
suspenseful Mysteries with terrifying
tension David Cronenberg The Man Behind
movies like video drone and the fly has
a well-earned reputation as the king of
body horror his son Brandon Cronenberg
has proven that the Apple doesn't fall
far from the tree the younger Cronenberg
followed in his Father's Footsteps by
making his own creative and gory horror
films starting with anti-viral in 2012
and following its up eight years later
with possessor it's important to note
that possessor exists in two drastically
different forms a heavily censored
version and the completely uncensored
possessor and Kurt which received his
own full release the censored version
scales back drastically on the film's
sexuality along with its violence and
Gore which has a major impact on the
overall effectiveness of the film that
extends to the opening scene possessor
uncut begins with a cold open scene that
depicts an assassination rather than a
typical movie assassination that might
be conducted with a sniper rifle this
kill is over the top violent featuring
excessive stabbing followed by a graphic
suicide by cop ending for the Assassin
but there's a Twist after the Assassin
dies she's revealed to have been an
innocent person who was possessed by the
true assassin via sci-fi technology the
seniors gratuitously violent on a
literal level but becomes increasingly
terrifying as the thought-provoking
questions of film raisers regarding Free
Will sink in cat's people started out as
a subtle and restrained horror film made
within the restrictions of the 1940s
Hollywood studio system when Paul
Schrader decided to remake the film in
1982 the story was no longer constrained
by the haze code of day's purse Trader
and screenwriter Alan Ormsby took the
original premise of a woman who fears
that sexual interaction will turn her
into a giant cat and ratcheted
everything up several notches from the
very first scene of the movie It's Made
clear that the 80s version of cat people
is a world apart from the original and
that it's going to hold nothing back the
film begins and an otherworldly desert
Locale as the when the nurse fields of
skulls buried beneath the surface a
young woman is bound to a tree as a
sacrifice to a panther words instead of
the panther mauling or eating her it's
implied that it actually impregnates her
with a half human half Panther child
ritualistic bestiality and cross-species
Offspring a rather taboo subjects the
most horror films wouldn't dare touch
upon but Schrader's cup people is a
unique animal
Invasion of the Body Snatchers has a
classic sci-fi horror film from 1956
based on Jack Finney's novel The Body
snatches the 1978 remake was able to
push the horror elements much further
because of advancements and special
effects along with the fact that the
Hollywood production code have been
repealed in the intervening years just
like the previous Incarnation Philip
Kaufman's version of Invasion of the
Body Snatchers tells the story of alien
copies secretly taking the place of real
human beings the Remake swaps a small
town Locale of the original for an urban
San Francisco setting injects a strong
dose of body horror via the alien
Transformations and delves into greater
detail regarding the alien's arrival on
Earth rather than starting out in any
sort of humanoid form the alien entity
first appears as a difficult to describe
biological material somewhere between
seed water and smoke the opening scene
tracks the Journey of this alien
substance from its planet of origin all
the way down into Earth's atmosphere
where it becomes Lost In The Rain
there's something truly terrifying about
just how easy it is for the alien
substance chance to reach the planet and
spread throughout the population without
anyone noticing the knowledge that it
may already be too late by the time the
human characters notice makes the
alien's arrival chilling from the get-go
you're evolving into a new life form
come and watch
Toby Hooper's 1974 horror Masterpiece
The Texas Chainsaw Massacre kicked off a
long-lasting legacy of sequels remakes
prequels and reboots but none of the
subsequent movies have ever held a
candle to the original though sometimes
and fairly written off as trashy and
exploitative it's often hailed as one of
the best and one of the scariest horror
films ever made and those scares kick
off right away with the film's opening
scene given that the film was made on an
extremely low budget it makes sense that
a Texas Chainsaw Massacre opens with a
sequence that is simple yet incredibly
effective the documentary style
narration provided by John larroquet
sets the stage for the violence and
lends a sense of authenticity to the
events that follow compounded by the
grungy realism of hoopa's visual
aesthetic the first shots of the film
are glimpses of corpse and the flashes
of a camera accompanied by some of the
creepiest sound effects ever put into a
horror film the final visual of the
opening scene is a grave robbed
amalgamation of corpses assembled
together and impaled on the top of a
pointy gravestone sending chills through
viewers before a single living character
has even graced the screen writer and
director are we asked to have followed
up his excellent debut feature film
hereditary with another strong horror
outing in the form of 2019's Midsummer
the story mostly revolves around a group
of naive Americans who head to an
isolated Swedish Village for a festival
that only happens once every 90 years of
course the whole thing turns out to be
much darker than they expected and a
terrible fate befalls them all but
before the festivities get underway the
film starts out much closer to home for
protagonist Dany the beginning of
Midsummer might just be the most
disturbing and heartbreaking sequence in
the entire film while Dany is away from
home her depressed sister kills herself
via car exhaust which also leads to both
of her parents dying by asphyxiation
this intro sequence isn't really a
traditional horror movie scare but more
like a real life one and the emotional
trauma it unleashes on Danny is
terrifying on the deepest possible level
no no
no no no no
with the opening scene being such a gump
punch it's hard for the rest of
midsummar to live up to him even as
Elders jump off cliffs and people are
burned alive many viewers will still be
left believing that the movie peaked
with its opening scene Alexander aha
would eventually become known as the
Director of mainstream horror remakes
and sequels like The Hills Have Eyes and
Piranha 3D but his second directorial
efforts high tension was one of the
defining films of the new French
extremity movements the basic plots is
just about as straightforward as you can
get in the horror genre a nameless
killer with a razor burst into a cottage
to slaughter the family inside and a
tense blood-soaked cat and mouse game
follows what makes a Bare Bones
narrative work for the majority of the
runtime is aha's slick grounded
Direction and his unflinching portrayal
of extreme violence The Kills in high
tension it all ratcheted up intensely
enough to feel fresh and shocking within
a genre prone to desensitizing fans the
film's opening scene sets the tone and
lets you know that high tension aims to
shock and disgust By the 7-minute Mark
the necrophiliac killer is shown
violating a woman's severed head setting
the bar for the level of depravity that
the rest of the film will indulge in the
film's nonsensical twist ending throws
the opening scene and much of the plot
into question but that doesn't change
the impact it has upon first watch
the legendary George Romero followed up
his genre defining 1968 zombie film
Night of the Living Dead But the equally
revolutionary Dawn of the Dead exactly
one decade later in 2004 Dawn of the
Dead was remade by Zack Snyder as his
feature film debut having made a name
for himself as a director of music
videos while Romero's original version
is a vastly superior film overall
Snyder's remake does boasts one hell of
an opening sequence after while very
well may be the last normal day of her
life Anna wakes up to see her husband
attacked by a zombified child after she
fights her way out of the house the film
then widens its scope to briefly
showcase the start of the zombie
apocalypse and things aren't looking
good giving a perspective on the very
start of the zombie takeover is an
element that is unique to Snyder's
remake while the rest of the film
utilizes the same shopping mall setting
as Romero's original The Dawn of the
Dead remake never manages to quite live
up to the high bar set by its terrifying
opening sequence but it remains an
entertaining zombie flag that stands out
well enough from the sea of zombie
movies that came out in the 2000s after
being nominated for the best director
Oscar for his 2001 film o'holland Drive
David Lynch took a five-year break from
feature filmmaking while working on
shorts and music videos when he returned
to the Silver Screen Lynch went back to
his roots with Inland Empire to deliver
his most bizarre and fully experimental
work since a razor head Inland Empire is
three hours long cryptic shot on ugly
low resolution digital video and most
importantly absolutely terrifying Lynch
holds nothing back opening the film with
a purely experimental sequence that
doesn't seem to have anything to do with
the rest of the film on Face Value the
simple visual of a needle scratching
along a record feels intense and
threatening the way Lynch presents it
with off kills or extreme close-ups
height and sound design and superimposed
images of what might be the inside of a
human body or something else entirely
the opening scene progresses directly
from the image of a hypnotic needle to a
hotel where a man and woman converts
with unsubtitled dialogue in an
unidentified language their actions
aren't all that's out of the ordinary
but their faces are blurred beyond
recognition and rather unsettling
lynchian way the intro is strange and
frightening and equal measure which
perfectly sets the tone and atmosphere
of the film that follows
the story that happened yesterday
but I know it's tomorrow
it doesn't make sense but gutsen is a
divisive underground horror film from
1989 directed by E Elias marriage
marriage would go on to make a few more
conventional movies later on in his
career including the excellent horror
comedy shadow of the vampire but Gotham
is on the extreme end of the
experimental Spectrum though its
avant-garde stylings are proven divisive
his presentation is undeniably
unsettling the opening scene of
Forgotten as a power to serve as instant
nightmare fuel for even the most
hardcore horror fans grainy high
contrast black and white footage shows a
grotesque version of God committing
suicide by repeatedly slashing at their
stomach with a straight razor the highly
stylized visuals make it a bit difficult
for the viewer to tell exactly what they
are looking at but that somehow only
makes the whole thing even freakier the
minimalist sound design as to the
disturbing nature of the scene there's
no music just natural Ambience and the
quiet sound of the body's rocking
movements this is an opening scene that
serves as a litmus test for the rest of
the film audiences will either be
enthralled by its grotesque and
experimental nature or want to jump ship
immediately we can't blame them either
way
foreign